ya hablamos de lo importante que es el
carbono para la vida la biología y para
las reacciones químicas también dijimos
que incluso existe todo un campo
dedicado a la química orgánica que
estudia la química de las moléculas que
involucran al carbón pero una de las
cosas más comunes con las que se une el
carbono es consigo mismo y con
hidrógenos existe toda una clase de
moléculas que solo están hechas de
carbonos e hidrógeno a este tipo de
moléculas se les conoce como
hidrocarburos hidrocarburos existen
muchos tipos de hidrocarburos pero
también existen otras moléculas que
tienen partes conformadas por
hidrocarburos por eso son muy
interesantes de estudiar y bueno aquí
tenemos tres ejemplos de hidrocarburos y
miren todos tienen el prefijo et porque
tienen una cadena con dos carbonos si
quieren estudiar cómo nombrar a los
hidrocarburos o incluso a los compuestos
orgánicos en general los
todas que vean la sección dedicada a
química orgánica de khan academy
entonces todos tienen el prefijo et
porque esa es la cadena de carbonos más
larga que tenemos todos tienen dos
carbonos pero miren el final es
diferente de este lado tenemos eta no
eso es porque tenemos un enlace simple
después por acá tenemos la terminación
en o porque aquí tenemos un doble enlace
y finalmente por acá tenemos la
terminación y no porque tenemos un
triple enlace entonces el término
general para una cadena de carbonos que
no tiene dobles o triples enlaces es
alcano esta molécula es un arcano y
tiene dos carbonos después el término
general cuando tenemos carbonos unidos
por un doble enlace es un el que no
déjenme escribir eso aquí tenemos un
arcano
es el término general para una cadena de
carbonos que solo tiene enlaces simples
específicamente este es el etano después
tenemos un el que no y por acá un al
'chino' pero pensemos un poco en cómo
este enlace afecta a la geometría de una
molécula vamos a ver aquí tenemos un
enlace simple y se forman dos tetraedros
donde cada uno de los carbonos se
encuentra en el centro por ejemplo del
lado izquierdo cuando dibujamos un
enlace así significa que se encuentra
hacia nosotros y cuando lo dibujamos con
líneas punteadas significa que está
lejos de nosotros entonces vamos a
dibujar un tetraedro esta sería la base
y después la parte de arriba nos queda
hacia el otro carbono este carbono nos
queda en el centro y podemos dibujar
otro tetraedro que ahora tenga este
carbono en el centro
este carbono es la punta y el tetraedro
se ve así ahí está entonces al menos
para esta molécula la geometría es muy
parecida a 2 tetraedros que se traslapan
y cómo estos carbonos están unidos con
un enlace simple los dos tetraedros
pueden rotar pueden rotar alrededor del
enlace simple pero las cosas cambian
cuando tenemos un doble enlace miren
cuando tenemos un doble enlace como éste
eso obliga a todos los átomos a que se
encuentren en el mismo plano así que el
éter no es plano el doble enlace obliga
a que todo se quede en el mismo lugar no
hay rotación y finalmente cuando tenemos
un triple enlace aquí tampoco hay
rotación pero además la molécula es
línea entonces cuando hablamos de la
geometría estamos hablando de cómo se
arreglan estas moléculas en tres
dimensiones y bueno por si tienen
curiosidad
es un componente del gas natural la
mayor parte del gas natural es metano
vamos a escribir el gas natural es en su
mayor parte metano que sólo tiene un
carbono unido a cuatro hidrógenos pero
también podemos encontrar un poco de
etanol en el gas natural ahora el eterno
también conocido como etileno es muy
utilizado en la industria química pero
lo más interesante es que se encuentra
como una hormona dentro de las plantas
que ayuda a que las frutas maduren y
finalmente el latino mejor conocido como
acetileno como es muy inflamable y
alcanza temperaturas muy altas es muy
utilizado como combustible para los
sopletes entonces todos estos se parecen
pero se usan para cosas muy diferentes y
podríamos seguir todo el día viendo
diferentes tipos de hidrocarburos pero
aquí les tengo algunos que son un poco
más raros
estas son tres moléculas que podemos
encontrar en la gasolina de los coches
aunque hay muchas más si agregamos un
poco de oxígeno las mezclamos y las
ponemos en un motor se queman muy bien
son muy buenos combustibles pero solo
para familiarizarnos un poco
este es el penta no es un arcano de 5
carbonos 1 2 3 4 5 5 carbonos en la
cadena más larga por eso se llama
ventana y como todos los demás enlaces
son hidrógenos en lugar de ver todas las
6h se pueden encontrar lo dibujado así
cada vértice representa un carbono así
no tenemos que escribirlos y si no hay
otro átomo al que esté unido el carbono
podemos suponer que lo demás son
hidrógenos esta es otra forma de
representar al pantano que es igual a
todo esto y observen que tiene esta
forma porque los carbonos buscan tener
una forma tetraedro
ahora por acá tenemos el ciclo hexano
también es un arcano porque no tenemos
dobles enlaces x es el prefijo para
indicar que hay 6 carbonos en la cadena
más larga que en este caso forman un
ciclo 1 2 3 4 5 6 y en lugar de ser una
cadena abierta aquí se une formando un
ciclo finalmente por acá tenemos algo un
poco más complejo pero vamos a ver al
final tenemos en qué significa que en la
cadena más larga hay un doble enlace
después el prefijo wood significa que en
la cadena más larga hay 4 carbonos mire
1 2 3 4 carbonos pero después en el
carbono 2 además del doble enlace
también tenemos un grupo metilo es decir
con un carbono porque met es el prefijo
para indicar que sólo hay un carbono así
que el objetivo de este vídeo es que se
familiaricen
con los hidrocarburos y que conozcan qué
tan útiles son en química porque en
biología verán muchas moléculas que
tienen partes conformadas por cadenas de
hidrocarburos y así podremos analizar
las propiedades asociadas con ellas